so congratulations on the last time
thank you where was your head at when
you're putting this on together
oh
um lots of places I was really excited
about
um basically seeing if I could make an
album about the extreme reactions that
loneliness causes which is not always
just sad it sounds like a downer title
but I think that
um actually loneliness can cause you to
do some pretty exciting things as well
so I think during my off time that's
something I wanted to explore is that a
state that you're comfortable being in
like being alone being lonely do you
find you're more creative in that state
or are you just like I just want to
chill and watch a movie like what's the
vibe like for you I need both things
like I need I need people for sure to
like feel happy and connected I think
that's extremely important but
um more and more I'm actually not as
frightened as like of my loneliness as I
think I used to be I sort of need my off
time to kind of recalibrate and battery
charge I guess yeah yeah nice uh how
about you are you an alone person I
enjoy a bit of a the balance yeah I
really like you know if I'm alone in my
car or I'm just going on a walk and just
whatever yeah like that's I need that
too yeah I think that's important
um beach house is super fun yes and it's
like it immediately sets you up yes
thank you
it is funny it is very fun it's a very
fun song well immediately like even in
the video it sets you up for the journey
you're gonna go on with this song is it
is it like
because I've heard the same sort of
stories maybe not word for word from
people that are single that I know yeah
but like is that what the life is like
is that are those stories coming from
real experience I mean first of all
beaches is absolutely the silliest song
on the album yeah um it's a flavor for
sure but it is uh based off of my very
short but extremely hilarious experience
on a dating app yes
um and and then the more I got to
talking out the people about it the more
I realized that everyone had like
similar horror stories and and then when
I was working with Nate Seifert and Alex
hope that other two collaborators on the
song
um we just had like almost like a a
board up of like just shout out bad
ideas and it was it was the it was a
really joyful right I think the most
hilarious uh antidote was uh you know
probably gonna Harvest your organs you
went a little far but then we decided
once you go that far it's really hard to
reel it back so there you have it I
would like to say that this is the
person who has lake house in Canada so
the most polite way to say that they
might Harvest your organs it's going to
to be the way a Canadian does it somehow
right like I read I had to do a Canadian
Shadow I don't know like when I think
about dating apps like people haven't
done with science as far as like how
they know which direction to swipe like
are there other red flag signs for you
where you look at them and you go okay
now I know what I'm looking for and what
what to watch out for I I don't like
I want to be careful because I think
dating apps can be really wonderful so
my experience was
but I think a lot of people I know have
found like true true love
um I so I don't know I think this was
just a brief experience in in the data
world and then I I got out quick because
I got a click with a song that's it yeah
yeah so for you at this stage what do
you how do you value success like what
do you look at and go this is this is
success for me at this stage
um I really put a lot of of stock into
the the creativity of the artwork um the
album I guess the music comes first
always
um and then if I can create an album
that I'm really proud of I have a lot of
fun kind of shaping a world around that
so I'm getting to put on a live show and
getting to kind of you know bring an
audience into that world with you is is
the most joyful thing ever so I think
that to me is success is getting to do
that with my life is all I really want
is being out in front of people the best
part
um it's I think it's one of the best
parts but I equally really love this as
much as we talked about like that being
around people being kind of alone I
really love the creative
um Studio space as well of like when the
idea is just being sparked and you're
kind of chipping away at it there's
something really joyful about that and
then yeah like you're getting to deliver
it in front of a crowd is a different
kind of Joy one of your collaborators
that you work with a lot of Jack
antonops yeah I you know I got asked
about because you have a long
relationship together in creation and so
what's it like to have someone who you
can lean on who who you can take
criticism from who you can collaborate
with on that level
Jack is really lovely to work with I
think
um he he actually I think is really good
at trying to bring out your uniqueness
so he's working with an artist I don't
think that he's there to critique so
much as and just sort of sort of figure
out what it is that's unique about you
and let you feel kind of brave enough to
share it so with him I think I've
written some of the most playful and
some of the most introspective songs of
like my whole catalog yeah yeah you
recently posted about the 10th
anniversary of Kiss celebrating that
um what's your relationship now to that
album to those songs when you look back
on them uh how do you feel about it now
I have a warm place in my heart for that
album it was made in a very short period
of time and I was just kind of learning
about what it was that I loved about pop
music so I look at it as sort of like my
baby entrance into the world of pop
music before I kind of got my variants a
little bit but
um really fun memories around that it
was a really exciting time of my life
and um uh yeah I a lot of Joyful kind of
chaos that I can't really all put
together but I generally a really fond
feeling I remember being in your orbit
like that you know being part of TV and
being in your orbit at that time and how
exciting that was yeah even to just
think about you in that time you know
when you think back to
um the collaboration back then is there
any advice that you would give her
oh what to give your younger self advice
is always a tricky question because
um it's so easy in hindsight to see a
bunch of things that you would do
differently I have like a list of things
absolutely but I think number one would
be let's just slow down as much as I
could there was such like a fast pace of
things that sometimes just to even like
stop and really appreciate the chaos as
it was happening I really was grateful
for every roller coaster ride that I was
on but there wasn't a lot of like breaks
right to take it in so I think if I was
getting to talk to my younger self I'd
be like God away for the weekend just
celebrate for a minute you know yeah
I'll have to do that now now you can do
that it doesn't feel like you could back
then like it wouldn't it wouldn't have
felt like you would have been here
before I think I'm a little bit of a
workaholic for sure I still kind of get
criticized for being that way but it's
in my blood I I think because my work is
so passionate it's hard to kind of see
it as that and sort of I'm like I eat
sleep and breathe it a little bit but it
is really important to take time off too
so I think that's what I would tell my
younger self as like step number one is
like slow down girl yeah do you
do you believe in writing down your
goals like do you write them down and
look at them and check in that's so
funny you asked that I believe in even
saying your goal out loud to at least
one other human being that sounds like
really like and what's the reason behind
that because I feel like you have to be
brave enough to say it to one other
person like the most ridiculous thing
that you're almost ashamed to want you
have to like get used to hearing
yourself say it out loud to someone have
it land on other ears you know and also
so hold yourself accountable in a way do
you think I things that I don't think
you should be around like shooting that
the thing you're going to do to everyone
before you've done that that can be
really dangerous and kind of pressure
filled but one person you trust to kind
of write down yeah write down your
secret dreams but then also kind of like
read them out to somebody one other
person I think that's kind of cool is
there a goal you have in mind right now
that you're
totally focused on like what's what's
the next thing
I mean I want to keep chewing I want to
keep making music that's always like a
uh what album can I make next kind of
feeling is is just in my blood for sure
but I think yeah I have a whole list of
goals I'm really excited about getting
to shift
um Direction at some point into kind of
the Broadway World I don't know what
that looks like but that's always been a
dream of mine to kind of redirect focus
into theater but right now I'm just
enjoying getting to tour and celebrate
this album The Loneliest time can you
tell me about what this song means
first of all it was a dream come true
because roof is running right agreed to
be on it which was not a little feat um
I've been a fan of him forever since I
heard poses I think it's like while
listening to that song that I decided
that I wanted to get into the to the
world of songwriting
um so fast forward 10 years later we're
in Los Angeles and we'd written the song
me and Nate Seifert and Kyle Shearer and
at the end there's this dream sequence
because it's a five minute song and it
so was reminiscent to me of like an
almost Rufus rainbow type Melody that I
was like can you imagine if we could get
Rufus to sing the Harmony on this and
then one thing led to another and I
emailed him I call it light stocking I
lightly stopped politely and at some
point he agreed to come he turns out he
lives like 15 minutes away from my house
in Los Angeles so he came over one day
to the studio and tried it and and his
voice sounded so good with that like
deep vibrato that he ended up it just
became a full like duet Islands in the
Stream that's what we are and I'm very
excited to hear Rufus do Disco oh and it
suits him so well so I'm really proud of
it but yeah this song is about the
extreme reaction that loneliness has
that when you are alone and you don't
have connection around you sometimes you
will think it's a good idea to run over
to your ex's house in the middle of the
night and rekindle things Maybe not
maybe that's not a good idea don't do it
how often do you find yourself in that
situation where you're like I'm having a
dream come true moment right now
often often I feel very Charmed in my
mom said I was born with like a little
lightning bolt somewhere in terms of
like a lucky streak and I think she's
not wrong I do feel like there's many
moments where I'm pinching myself and
then I I'm really learning that like you
should always you should always ask I
think I think a lot of people stop
connections that could be really
brilliant by thinking oh the person will
say no and I think from Tom Hanks on
I've just learned you can always ask
just ask group is right he might say yes
and the worst thing is he could say no
but when he was there singing in my
little Studio that I had made during
coven actually on the mic the first
person to ever use it I was just
pinching myself couldn't believe it yeah
it feels for a long time in your life
that no is the worst thing that can ever
happen to you it's not that bad I've had
lots of people say no too but when they
say yes it's really magical yeah so this
you know this uh this song is about is
about that is this album like what is
the Journey of this album is this about
that or
um well basically this album isn't not
just one theme I think well it is in a
way it's the theme is the reactions of
loneliness but those reactions are very
unique and different it can cause you to
do a crazy thing like join a dating app
with features then it can cause you to
fantasize about running it over to your
ex's house in the middle of the night or
be really introspective or long for your
family and so I guess if there's one
theme it's a theme that takes you on it
a bunch of different Journeys and that's
what I'm hoping this album will do as
well